[Evans] So we could write all the code we need to loop through elements of a list
just using while.
We'd be able to do anything we want. It would just be a little more complicated than we want.
Python provides a simpler way to loop through elements of the list,
and that's called a for-loop.
The structure of a for-loop is like this.
We have the keyword for followed by a name,
and this is a new name for a variable that we can introduce,
then the keyword in followed by a list,
and this is any expression which evaluates to a list followed by a colon.
So this is quite similar to what we've seen for the structure of a while loop
and an if statement with a block inside the for.
What a for-loop like this means is that for each element in the list
we're going to assign that element to the name and evaluate the block.
And we'll do that in order going through the list.
So using for, we can define the procedure printallelements
using much less code than we needed using while.
We have a for statement where we'll introduce the name e as the variable name.
We're going through the list p.
For each element what we want to do is just print that element.
So let's step through what happens when we use the for-loop
calling printallelements, passing in the list we've defined and stored
in the variable mylist.
This is a list with 3 elements.
The first 2 are numbers, 1 and 2, and the third is the list 3, 4.
So when we created mylist, that created a list object that looks like this.
It has the 3 elements,
numbers in the first 2 and the list 3, 4 in the third one.
When we pass that to printallelements, the variable p will refer to that object.
When we execute the loop, what happens is the variable e
is assigned to the first element of p.
So initially, e will refer to this value.
We execute the body of the loop with that as the value of e,
so that will print out the value 1. Then we continue.
The next time through the loop, e will refer to the second element of p.
We evaluate the body of the loop, printing out that value, which is 2.
Then we continue in the loop.
The next time, e will refer to the third element of p, which is the list 3, 4.
This will print out the list 3, 4.
At this point we've gone through all the elements of p and the for-loop is done.
Execution would continue here.
In this case there's no statement there,
so we're done executing the procedure and we return.